well drought across the southwest is
helping fuel those fires and causing the
colorado river to shrink
right now the lake is at 1067 feet its
lowest level ever
in the year 2000 the water came right up
to the top of hoover dam
during the mega drought the lake has
dropped 140 feet
a nasa satellite is documenting the loss
of water stored in the mountains
reservoirs
and even underground aquifers jt
williams described to cbs news this
morning
what the project has found and is that
what we're seeing here
are we seeing that progression that's
exactly right so these are some images
that we've taken from april 2010
2015 and 2021 showing this steady drying
progression
of water in the west given how severe
this
drought is and how long term how long
would it take to recover from something
like this
we would need a solid decade of really
wet years
which is probably just not going to
happen
williams says what the west needs more
than anything is snow
snowpack in the mountains melts
throughout the summer
and it flows into the reservoirs